hiding on point oh my balls I mean how
many how many movie posters have you
seen with LGBTQ people in them Brokeback
Mountain oh yeah that is big one we're
not as represented as we should be for
being as big a percentage of the
population as we are like there was a
token and you're like oh there's just
one why is it only just one always you
don't identify with that one token it's
like who can you identify with trans
people are people too and you know we're
here we've been around III know for a
fact that having actual bisexual people
out in media would have made my
coming-out experience way easier because
I fell prey to the the mindset that you
had to be one of the other for the
longest time your eyelashes tickling me
I'm ready I'm excited
all of you listen II would be about any
more ghost is actually one of my mom's
favorite movies I'll be recreating the
Magic Mike movie poster yeah I shouldn't
see much of your eyes I'm so excited
it's one of my favorite films trans guys
can bring it too and I just want to show
the world we're about to pose for The
Fault in Our Stars movie I have
personally never seen that also touches
base for high school audiences because
even today in the media the few LGBTQ
represented films it's typically an
older generation you're like eating my
eyelashes your eyelashes tickling my lip
I'm excited for this photo shoot I can't
wait to be dr i can't wait to be with my
fighter
I can't wait to me I can't wait to be
Cher I'm really excited about taking
this like iconic gay movie and putting a
twist on it where the gay characters
aren't just the best friends in the
background but we're like front and
center and you know what we shouldn't be
hidden [ __ ] we're people to super pumped
I'm so happy
can I be Superman I warn you I brought
kryptonite so you are my kryptonite I
don't know if that's a compliment or not
I think that went great I was feeling
myself
it was tickling my nose the chest hairs
a little bit bad kisser yeah you do
whoa oh it was cool I was a little bit
nervous at first you know we all have
scars and stuff that we're becoming more
comfortable with but I had a ball
overall and I love doing Magic Mike I
think that it's important to show trans
youth and LGBTQ youth that the options
are just endless the sky's the limit I
just think it's important for LGBT media
to exist
I feel like movies and film are you know
it's an escape for people and it's hope
for people so I feel like we should be
represented in that hope [ __ ] yeah yes
should be more LGBTQ people and movie
[ __ ] I think also seeing different types
of gay men in the forefront is important
to not all gay men fit into the like
role that is carved out in the media and
don't look like that I feel like a lot
of times if you don't look like that can
be a struggle
it's badass I felt so badass looking at
it I was like wow the kids that are
growing up these days they should see
more of their people like that is gonna
help them like become more of themselves
and like be you know whole you can do
anything and be anything that you want
to